اذا نقلت قوات المواليه لروسيا انها صدت
محاولته هجوما اوكرانيه على مواقع روسيه
قرب مدينه جورلوفكا شمالا دونتس القوات
المواليه لروسيا صورا قالت انها الاستهداف
مجموعتين من الدبابات والمدرعات
الاوكرانيه كانت تحاول التقدم باتجاه
مواقعها مؤكده احباط الهجوم وتكبيد القوات
الاوكرانيه خسائر وصفاتها بالكبيره
في دنيا امينه مرحبا بك من جديد اذا اضافه
الى ذلك والجهه المقابله بالتاكيد سواء
القوات الروسيه او حتى المواليه لروسيا
تتحدث عن هجوم مضاده حيث انت تصدت له من
الجانب الاوكراني اجمل لنا الصوره
تم تحيه طيبه محمد في الحقيقه يمكن تقسيم
الجبهات الى ثلاثه اقسام رئيسيه هنا في
مقاطعه كوفي المنطقه ايضا الجنوبيه من
اوكرانيا وتحديدا خرسون وزاباولوجيا
بالنسبه للمحور الاول الذي شهد قصفا
متبادلا ومحاولات اوكرانيه بحسب السلطات
المواليه لروسيا هنا في دنياتك لاقتحام
دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني الجيش الروسي
شهدتها منطقه تقع الى الشمال من غور لافكا
هي مدينه تبعد بنحو 30 كيلومترا عن
دونياسك حيث نحن وايضا تحدثت عن ان صد هذا
الهجوم الاوكراني
ادى الى وقوع خسائر وصفتها الكبيره في
صفوف الجيش الاوكراني وايضا في عتاده
العسكري الى الشمال من مقاطعه دونيسكو
تحديدا قرب الضخموت موقع ريبار العسكري
تحدث عن مح متواصله للجيش الاوكراني في
محاوله لاختراق دفاعات الجيش الروسي وقال
ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت بها المدفعيه
الثقيله الليله الماضيه بلدتين قريبتين من
مدينه بخموت لكن كل تلك المحاولات بحسب
الموقع العسكري الروسي باءت بالفشل هنا في
دنياس هناك ايضا محاولات متكرره بحسب
السلطات المواليه لروسيا يحاول من خلالها
الجيش الاوكراني استهداف مواقع قريبه من
دونيات والحديث عن محيط مطار دنيتك الدولي
والمناطق الواقعه خلف مدينه افديفكا التي
ما زالت تشهد قصفا متبادلا بين الجانبين
طوال اليومين الماضيين الى الجنوب هناك
ايضا معلومات تتحدث عن صدد محاولات لتقدم
القوات الاوكرانيه في محور الجنوبي
وتحديدا قرب اوغليدار وفي مارينكا ايضا في
بلده نفض نيتكي هذه البلده التي قالت
اليوم مواقع روسيه ان الجيش الروسي غنمه
مدرعات اوكرانيه غربيه الصنع وتحديدا
بريطانيا خلال تلك المحاولات التي مازال
الجيش الاوكراني
يقوم بها من اجل اقتحام دفاعات الجيش
الروسي جنوبا وفيزا باروجيا الاداره
العسكريه والمدنيه الروسيه في المدينه
اكدت اليوم ان الدفاعات الجويه تصدت لهجوم
صاروخي اوكراني على مدينه بيرديانس التي
تقع على ضفاف بحر ازوف ولم تتحدث عن اي
استهدافات بتلك الصواريخ وفي منطقه خرسون
وتحديدا على الضفه اليسرى قال موقع ايضا
ربال العسكريه اليوم بان الجيش الروسي
مازال يحاول يحاول
اخراج القوات الاوكرانيه التي عبرت النهر
ووجدت لها موقع القدم على الضفه اليسرى
وتحديدا قرب